this has been my first year in preschool  with a class of my own teaching  alongside another queer neurodivergent  educator queer and neurodivergent what  the [ __ ] is neurodivergent and we have  been rocking our two's class we've been  talking about gender and skin color and  consent and stopping our bodies have  autonomy it's been fabulous  okay get these crazies out of the school  i swear to god but our teaching team is  shifting and a new person is being  onboarded someone with many years of  experience so today at the lunch table  when the topic of gender and genitals  came up one of our students plainly  looked up and said well i'm a girl today  stop it okay how does genitals just  casually come up at the lunch table how  get these people out of our schools  thank you